on est en pleine forêt en pleine forêt
coréenne jeong joo si je ne prononce pas
trop trop mal tout autour de vous les
arbres sont tortueux
apparaissent assez
subrepticement pour finalement ou ap
vous emmener dans une ambiance assez
particulière
drôle de paradoxe chez b vienne où il
nous invite d'abord à nous projeter dans
une ambiance proche de la méditation
dans l'obscurité
mais cela sera de courte durée car le
photographe coréen adore la lumière sur
tous les débuts et les fins de journée
l'homme est tombé amoureux de la forêt
de chambord pendant près d'un an
il a photographié les arbres du domaine
avec une prédilection pour les pins
symbole de longévité en corée du sud en
corée du sud
la web it baby ou le pain est un arbre
vraiment ça crée un petit peu comme le
chêne chesneau qui est réputé pour être
un arbre fort de longévité et dans le
sud de la corée il y à ce sanctuaire des
rois coréen de la dynastie sylla qui est
un sanctuaire dans lequel il y a
énormément de pain et c'est de là que
tout est parti
drôle de clichés où les arbres ne sont
jamais vus dans leur totalité
pour arriver à un tel travail mais bien
nous aura pris des centaines de clichés
que de l'argentique principalement du
noir et blanc des heures et des heures
de patience et de technique pour arriver
à cette douceur méditative plein de
vitalité